marjorie taylor green a republican u.s
representative seen in that report said
her heart is full and has been speaking
to our correspondent mark stone
i am overjoyed my heart is really full
and just absolutely thrilled that the
supreme court justices overturned
roe versus wade with their jobs ruling
and i think this is a real answer to
prayer and the beginning of the real
work for the life life movement in
america there's no question that it has
it does divide the nation um the nation
appears to be on edge at the moment how
does how do you bring bring the country
back together with such a divisive
ruling well i think if you really look
at a lot of the polling
a lot of americans support life and are
against abortion especially when a lot
support abortion rights as well
well some do yeah no no most apparently
well you asked me how i feel about it
and i'm i'm explaining to you
many people support life especially here
in my home state but your job as a
politician is to bring people together
how do you do that after this my job as
a representative is to support the
constitution protect it protect people's
rights and freedoms and abortion is not
part of our constitution and one last
thing nancy pelosi said today that
there's there's an extraordinary
contradiction that at one level uh you
can you can argue that it is a
constitutional right
to have a gun uh but at the same time
you can say that it's not a
constitutional right to
have abortion choice nancy pelosi
doesn't really respect women's rights
because she's interested in putting
biological men in our sports in our
bathrooms so
she's you're introducing a separate
argument there what about what about the
answer to her
suggestion that this is an extraordinary
contradiction
i i don't i don't agree at all
protecting our gun rights gives
americans right to defend themselves and
that protects life and and ending
abortion also protects the life of the
unborn who can't protect themselves
either so whether we take away guns we
we take away americans rights to defend
themselves and if we if we keep abortion
like she wants then we continue to kill
innocent people on the way